il y à l'équipe des jaunes l'équipe des
rouges mais aussi l'équipe orange locaux
lanta de trappes diffère quelque peu de
la version réelle mais l'esprit est
conservé avec notamment le test redouté
des aliments les yeux bandés des
noisettes
ouais en tout quarante jeunes
participent à ce stage koh lanta pendant
les vacances au programme durant quatre
jours sport agilité endurance des
activités variées qui permettent de
rassembler dans la bonne humeur
l'ensemble des enfants de la ville
d'habitude les stages c'était donc un
stage de quatre jours soit cuisine soit
que sport basket foot activités
manuelles avec une sortie proposée à la
fin de la semaine
cette fois ci donc c'est tous les jeunes
qui sont mélangés toute la semaine sur 4
jours et qui s'affronteront vendredi sur
huit équipes pour pouvoir relever le
challenge du meilleur aventurier
cette animation est une première à
trappes et elle séduit les enfants fans
pour la plupart de l'émission de tf1 une
émission qui avec et 18 saisons au
compteur est beaucoup plus âgée que ces
jeunes aventuriers il va tout petit
j'aime bien regarder koh lanta du coup
j'ai voulu faire c'est quelque chose que
je regarde quand je suis chez ma grand
mère mais après on aura près gêne pas
juste quand je dors chez ma grand mère
je regardais après je la regarde tué
vendredi soir
et c'est trop dire que l'on sache pour
savoir qui sera le meilleur aventurier
de trappes le rendez vous est fixé
vendredi après midi au stade gravaud
pour prétendre au titre certains ont
encore beaucoup de travail